you can't talk about the moral decay in
society unless you're willing to have a
conversation about pornography
and we're going to have somebody on in
the future and we're going to dig into
this because i'm really interested in
what it's doing to men in particular
what it's doing to sexuality
what it's doing to young kids now and
what it's doing to relationships that
trickles out to community that trickles
out to country
but i saw this article
and it said las vegas hotels to deliver
vr porn
headsets via robot to lonely guests
las vegas who knew look at this virtual
reality headsets that have porn this is
no joke this is welcome to 22.
welcome to the moral decay that's 22
2022. visitors to las vegas won't even
need to leave their hotel rooms to get a
taste of sin city how convenient
vr bangers that's what they're called
okay
not hiding it at least at least they're
creative i gotta give them that a
company that specializes in pornographic
films especially tailored to
three-dimensional virtual reality
headsets they touched all the bases here
as my husband said they got the virtual
they got the porn it's like decay at
every level how can we wreck a society
let's do it let's see who bites
it's partnering with several vegas
hotels to offer helmets pre-loaded with
adult content to guests eager to indulge
their need for instant gratification
instant gratification by the way is the
enemy of success
it's the enemy you want to be successful
that need for instant gratification it's
going to get you it's going to wreck you
the idea to use the robots changed
everything abramovic said apparently
he's the ceo of vr bangers
stand-up guy we've even created some
special scenes to ensure that they offer
even greater levels of immersion and
realism
well look at that
i'm not even going to ask what that is
that tyler's put on the screen because i
don't want to know looks like some type
of robot i don't know what's coming out
of there that's the delivery robot oh
that's the delivery robot
how exciting
so again now you're a free man you're a
free woman you're an adult this is for
18 and up
you can do what you want
you can do what you want
but this is wrecking you
you know what they want they want you
sitting
in a hotel room you're in vegas get
outside you want to go meet somebody you
want to have some fun
go walk up to somebody strike up a
conversation go out dancing take someone
to dinner get some heat going on
make it happen
no
they want you sitting in your hotel room
like an overgrown baby
afraid of rejection afraid of the world
outside it's scary
they want you
watching
addicted to pornography that's totally
impossible for people to recreate in
real life that sets
the bar here for weirdness and craziness
so when you go to actually have sex with
a real live woman you're bored
right
and they want you paying for it because
it's it's constant cash flow the more of
a vegetable you are the more money they
make they don't care that society's in
decay they need society to be in decay
they need your relationship to be [ __ ]
up they need that to happen in order to
make money
they need your demand
for this product you know the free
market you know how it works you say we
don't want it that product does
so i'm inviting you to make it die
it's an invitation
i'm not going to force you
i don't force anything i believe in
freedom i believe in the marketplace
let it thrive or let it die but it's up
to you so i wanted to bring something
that i found because we are going to
talk in depth about pornography i think
it's a really important point but i
found this i did a quick search from
utah state university they did a great
job of talking about porn this is from
july of 2022 and the negative impacts
and they just outlined a few things here
pornography can have negative
consequences for both the user and his
or her intimate partner
some of the common damaging effects of
pornography for users can include
addiction isolation increased aggression
distorted beliefs and perceptions about
relationships and sexuality negative
feelings about themselves and neglecting
other areas of their lives
take a look at the list that they have
there user faces difficulty becoming
sexually aroused without pornography
that's not good
user loses interest and engages in fewer
sexual experiences with the partner that
they have why because well they're being
stimulated by the porn so they don't
need their partner anymore
hence there's distance that happens in
the relationship problems that arise in
the relationship
partner may view pornography used as
infidelity and a betrayal to the
relationships so people break up over
that
maybe your wife doesn't want you sitting
looking at some fake nonsense going on
she wants to connect with you in the
comfort of your own bedroom
it turns into a problem guess who wins
the people who make this garbage they
make a lot of money oh we broke up
another relationship now he'll really
want more porn it's not just men women
this goes for women too but the audience
is largely men for this kind of stuff if
you look at the demographics and the
breakdown it's just a reality
partner feel sexually inadequate and
threatened by pornography use then you
have all these insecurities that arise
in a relationship that become a problem
partner may feel that certain sexual
activities desired by user are
objectionable
why because you're watching this you're
watching porn all of a sudden you're
like wow now i'm bored of this let's
make it crazier oh let's make it before
you know it's like you're in a jungle
scene something's going on you don't
even it's madness you're not going to
recreate that on a saturday night in
your bedroom
so now that intimacy that real intimacy
that strengthens bonds that strengthens
you that makes you feel like a man
that goes away and instead you're this
guy that's got vr glasses on trying to
make something happen with a fake robot
in a porn scene and paying for it
talk about emasculating
they're not growing men they're taking
your manhood from you and you're letting
them do it
so stop
relationship trust decreases one or both
partners may be concerned about
children's exposure that's another thing
you got to think about you got to think
about how this trickles out and i know
sometimes you're a single guy out there
i'm talking to men now i'm talking to
the guys listening to this because as i
said there's going to be times that i
talk more to a woman in fact at the end
of this show i'm going to talk to women
because they're they're causing some
problems too that we need to set right
where i should say
i'm a woman as well i know that's
controversial but i am
but guys this stuff trickles out if
you're a dad if you're going to be a dad
one day
your relationship being a problem
because of this stuff it trickles out
everything you do trickles out think
about it it's like what happens at the
dinner table that goes wrong trickles
out to the community trickles out beyond
the community to the city to the state
to the country and now you have a
country that's in decay you have
intimacy that doesn't matter to people
anymore real intimacy you have bonds
between people that are getting broken
so please think about this you are
always entitled to make a choice for
yourself as an adult but you also need
to think about what the consequences are
of those decisions you want to get
feisty get feisty with your girl
it will be more fun i promise you then
stay and you will feel like a man after
that
that's not how you're gonna feel when
you take off your virtual reality
glasses and you take out your wallet and
you pay for your experience it's just
not
it's just not they're shrinking men
little by little you guys are shrinking
and i don't want shrunken men if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]